it's their second meeting in three
months and there's no shortage of issues
for the two leaders to chew over in view
of the fact that there are so many
serious issues around the world we need
an opportunity to find solutions we both
have responsibilities Germany but in
particular also Russia because Russia is
a permanent member of the Security
Council so we need to look for solutions
solutions on Syria will be difficult as
Merkel said there has been a reduction
in the fighting but the search goes on
for an end to the conflict the same goes
for Ukraine this is the first time
Vladimir Putin has met Merkel in Germany
since the Ukraine conflict began and
piece is still elusive of course we will
talk about Ukraine as the Chancellor
said in the context of settling the
crisis we are not making the progress we
might have hoped but there is no
alternative to the implementation of the
Minsk agreements this top level
relationship looks more active and more
cordial than it has for some years as
Merkel said earlier this week while
breakthroughs are unlikely talking
remains essential